how long does this kind of bond
volatility last and how long have the
shape companies like this the bond
volatility was talking about is really
from Treasuries so the 10-year treasury
yield at the beginning of this month was
2.1 two percent as we speak here today
about an hour goes 2.40 percent so
yields have increased 28 basis points
approximately month to date and that
results in a loss of principal on a bond
or a bond fund 2.4% right now I would
say this is one of the biggest questions
that a lot of people who I speak to have
at what point will hire benchmark yields
the Treasuries boons lead to wider
corporate spreads or it's or the extra
yield that investors demand over
benchmark rates and so far it hasn't
really gapped out that much the extra
cushion of yield it sort of held steady
even as interest rates right even as a
Treasury yields rise that said people
are waiting for what happened in the
taper tantrum when borrowing costs rise
to a certain level people who invested
in corporate debt are going to cycle
back into Treasuries going to cycle back
into a higher rated debt instead of
going with junk bonds or
investment-grade corporate bonds and
this could lead to a sort of widening of
borrowing costs that go beyond just you
know what's going on with Treasuries and
that could actually make a problem for
some of these companies that are
borrowing in a record well sure
especially we've seen a lot of companies
borrowing due in part to ma right you
don't want to repatriate the cash
overseas you gotta raise some bonds in
order to fund M&A so does that have a
ripple effect throughout the markets in
something like this well rates have gone
up and some companies are sensitive to
the overall rate they're paying you look
at big companies that don't we need the
money like Apple Computer they were very
opportunistic and took advantage of
extremely low rates and we look at the
yields they're paying one and a half to
two and a half percent that's pre-tax
after-tax the cost is about seventy
percent of that so it's really really
cheap capital e borrowing is a company
in the market today Heins which is doing
an approx size bond of ten billion
dollars and they have close to fifty
billion dollars in demand for it but to
Lisa's point if investors were to shy
away as we see some volatility in the
market does that yield wind up going up
and then eventually company a certain
companies are not gonna be able to go
into the debt
market well it really prices off of
Treasuries and spreads spreads have
widened in the investment grade market
around seven to eight basis points this
month and high-yield market about double
at fourteen fifteen sixteen basis points
so it's a combination of Treasury yields
going up in very small spread widening
well and I think that we were talking
before coming on here that so far
investors are still clamoring for this
stuff as you said with the Heinz deal in
fact they're 50 billion uh fifty that
it's so over allocated right now is is
really a significant at the same time
there could be a period of time in the
future when you've got corporate credit
worthiness that's deteriorating some
what you are seeing an increase in
defaults that made the number of
defaults in May and the US
speculative-grade market was the most
for a month since 2009 I mean this is
actually there is some concerns about
credit quality at this point that are
creeping in and you could see that
trickle into higher borrowing costs that
are more substantive at particularly in
a junk market because we have seen
investors pulled about five billion
dollars from funds and invest in the
junk rated debt market to the your point
if a non-credit where the company can't
raise cash do they go bankrupt and does
that accelerate right most of the
defaults were in the energy sector there
were a handful of companies that are
really challenged and struggling in
their bond prices reflect the challenges
they have they're in very low price
zones